you're january 6th you were in there on
january 6th
but they're just they're just letting
you wander free right now
i was going for
a transplant pigeon but all right
all right we got one winner he starts
talking to these people you know he's on
the other side of this he's talking to
these people
and then the easter bunny
the easter bunny literally comes up to
him
and moves him away from the people like
no no no
i'm in charge here okay
pelosi whose eyebrows keep moving
how is that
possible how is that i mean i've seen
some weird stuff
all due respect ladies and west palm
i've seen some weird work
and i brought the santa's on stage i
just looked at him and i went
and
[Applause]
nobody cares anymore gay people don't
care if they're okay well
my husband's gay i don't give a [ __ ]
is there any lesbians here
[Music]
he's a lesbian
i'm not a biologist i think he's
[Applause]
this country is not beyond saving thanks
to people like you
[Music]
god literally just got on the phone and
said dad endorse him
you know there's a consequence to being
conservative that there isn't for the
other side
regardless you get
do you realize the only hollywood people
that will talk to his family anymore are
the village people
the village people
big resurgence
[Music]
also the fact that that is her dad's
theme song
does he know what the song is about
i believe he calls it the gay national
rainbow
but but people like it and uh
they'll sue me they hate village people
let's go
[Music]
[Applause]